oh go to squarespace.com and use promo
code Hannibal for 10% off of your first
purchase 10% it's a double in I Bao
that's H aw I Bao
[Music]
hey I gotta stop this weird scatting it
I don't know what I'm trying to do with
this that's kind of hot a betta butta
butta butta you shut up every episo--
like that I start over so scatting
you're like hey but everybody ready uh
maybe it's a nervous tic
I didn't even sometimes I have weird
vocal nervous tics that I don't realize
I'm doing until I watch video listen to
myself without when I was hosting why I
would when I will introduce the musical
guest I was like please welcome over my
ego yeah oh [ __ ] is that dude That's not
me anyway excited child my own height
medicine [ __ ] anyways man we're here
Hannibal Buress tony trim special guest
Andrew barber oh hello how we doing I'm
doing our Angela barber thanks for
having me
sure waiter true rate of the website
fake short drive yes sir dot-com check
it out Chicago hip hop website how long
is the website been abroad this years
ten years ten years yes this is ten
years ten years in the game 2007 yeah
that was early in the blogging game it
was a very early very early 2007
that means you were getting like cool
kids exclusive tracks and [ __ ] yeah
that's real that's yeah you know the
cool kids are kind of the reason why I
started doing it really they were a big
part of it you know the reason I started
fake short drive and you know it's been
able to succeed there was such a void
here right you know what I mean
there was nobody covering it there was
nobody covering hip hop at the time
right like on the on the internet and it
was not cool well was that during like
the Flast Radames kids yep like okay
yeah kids sister kids sister exactly
that's right okay some of that era like
early treated crew man oh yeah Mike
Tarin though early on yeah yeah and it
was like the only people that were
getting national coverage on blogs or
websites were twisters comment on yeas
in the loop A's right yeah
all this cool stuff happening you know
there was national artists that were
coming here that were hot quote-unquote
online but they couldn't sell out yeah
you know a 300 person room we're like
the cool kids will have a line wrapped
around the corner down the street yeah
I'm like all right somebody needs to be
covering what's going on here is how it
was born that's what it was so it's just
you said I got a start a web site right
and it was a blogspot it was fake short
drive dot blot you remember the dot blog
yeah era yes no gotta blocks I had an
old black spot everybody had a block
blocks wide only about to post I
remember one was about my uncle like
stealing something from me when he was
on drugs and it's something else
that's what su post I remember that one
specifically and you get an award if you
can find it cuz I know you didn't delete
it somewhere my if you can find my block
spot the old blogspot it's probably
something for about 2006 or something
like that
I'll PayPal you $100 you can find my
whole box press and it's a handsome
Rambla at gmail.com so you said I'm
gonna start this website yep what was
your first post my first post was
probably you know what I should go back
and look I don't know if every because
I've had to transform the server a few
times but I think it was a cool kids
post
yeah I think so I believe that's what it
was but because that was a while was
super inspired by because it wasn't a
lot of the DIY scene wasn't like it was
poppin but it wasn't considered cool
because I feel like that was still kind
of the was a different era in rap it was
still kind of like you know people had
to be macho and you know even though
they weren't really hipsters everybody's
I mean we're not doing that hipster rap
that's hipster rap yeah it wasn't
hipster rap right he was just a
different sound very different sound
well it was a different sound and style
because they made it okay to wear like
tight jean right and [ __ ] yeah they had
they had their set ways you know well
that's what was the funny one on when I
saw Kanye arguing with Kid Cudi about
who invented skinny jeans yeah like Sir
Michael rocks yeah yeah yeah by about
two years for sure because people were
clowning on him like Oh up with that you
know from what they just didn't identify
with the big baggy you know Rocawear
jeans or whatever they wanted to do
something and that trend is still going
people
still rocking the skinny jeans like yeah
but you know that means the geneco's
about to come back yeah yeah would you
know light like wide legs I was already
coming back like the [ __ ] that I've been
seeing like and we've been ordering for
the shop you've just been like so like
raver pay like Juggalo pants big
straight leg big pants watch mark my
words you will see you by next season I
can that go with wrinkles zinc you know
what I used to rock and I thought it was
dope do you remember JW jeans West jeans
West was a mall store at Brickyard Mall
and a couple other malls you could buy
these terrible denim vest and gene
matching combos and I had this green
[ __ ] that I used to wear green pants
green vest with like a green t-shirt
that was striped with different kind of
tones of green and I thought I was the
[ __ ] or Bishop Don magic Juan it was it
was a terrible with it that color green
it was that type of great it was just a
terrible green and I'm glad that
smartphones went around then wait green
you said green denim green denim jeans
with a vest and a t-shirt under it that
was my go-to outfit that was my fit
wallet that was magic that was about
that little I'm about to kill him today
yes matching matching matching green top
green bottom yeah that yeah that's
basically like Canadian tuxedo yeah what
a night race man tonight it was clean
though the night it was clean for the
nineties
tonight but so what were you doing will
you're not from Chicago not originally
yeah not originally where'd you move
from
Indiana Indiana yeah yeah Bloomington
Indiana that's where I went to school
you went to school and went it went to
school at Indiana in D so you familiar
with Indiana State Road 37 I am I have a
[ __ ] trap 137 I got at least two
tickets when I was in college
listen his was just have a credit card
machine with you it's a worth let's just
swipe it up I don't I'm not coming back
to your garbage time
to go to court this is handle it here
what year did you graduate from old 404
that's the year that's the year I was
supposed to graduate okay okay that's
when I loved cop yeah that's when you
stopped going huh that's what I yeah we
went to Southern Illinois University
okay yeah it's the were you involved in
hip hop they're producing shows now
radio and I don't not really it was I
was just a hobby it's always been like
my lifelong passion forever I mean I
started listening to hip hop when I was
probably 7 years old like early yeah DJ
Jazzy Jeff and The Fresh Prince he's the
DJ I'm the rapper was my favorite was my
first tape okay right and I knew I
wanted to work in it but it wasn't
before the Internet it was not an easy
business to get into
unless you were like in New York like
cuz the industry wasn't even really in
LA at the time right like Interscope was
out there yeah like almost all the
labels were in New York yeah unless you
knew somebody like I used to have to
like fax my resume over to the labels
yeah cuz it was no you couldn't just eat
mail people you couldn't hit anybody
here Twitter what you know and like the
early two-thousands or whatever no not
at all so you effects from your own fax
machine oh would you go to the colonel
the currency college the student union
fax machine at Indiana University and
like I will just get a stack over of
like resumes and fax it to every single
label spent bad boy yeah yeah no limit
no no not no limit but no I would have
gotten no let me
you just didn't they did the fax machine
number was an accessible very secretive
they had kind of stopped popping around
that time yeah but yeah no limit wait
what years what you're you talking about
I mean this is like 2001 2000 yeah they
were there at their tail end at least
yeah it was cold I used to love no
limits promotional strategy you buy one
album and they promoted 30 other albums
in the sleeve and he had that those
thick that thick plastic yeah instead of
the jewel-case plastic yeah yeah oh man
I bought a silk Chaka Alva
when I didn't now that was great
marketing yeah
haze money and that like $9.99 $16 for
Silkk the Shocker CD think about that
yeah think about that and now like the
dude was going something like two
million copies and now he's just the
butt of all jokes nobody takes it
seriously well you can't just pull out a
Silkk the Shocker CD and be like yo this
[ __ ] well you try to put put a young kid
onto it now like I promised this was
good don't laugh at you they don't
understand it delete it but if it did it
ah let's see murder see murders in jail
for murder right yeah unfortunately you
can't rely on him for facts who the fact
checker is um I might be off but I'll be
on point
he never we had he didn't know Nate God
was dead what Tony didn't know Nate Dogg
was dead Tony me and it's like a week
ago me and Al Jackson is a couple months
ago months yeah we're talking about Nate
Dogg and then they don't been passed for
about six years yeah I didn't know a dog
was dead yeah just out and about in life
they can hear in fog and oh no like Oh
can't wait to [ __ ] plays the river to
the shot I was so distraught and over a
Snoop Dogg shows why I wonder what Nate
Dogg didn't vote for that why did you
think I move in celebrity circles you
probably would have seemed Nate Dogg
around some way I mean you know some
people go on how this baby was on
sabbatical I don't know I wish I could
have seen my face when he told me that
cuz I felt what my face did I felt what
my face did and it was mad forest it was
very natural and you thought you had to
think he was just kidding right oh no
yet I got Chipotle um yeah we were at
you Paul
it's malaria remember where how would I
be saying this [ __ ] was 9/11 huh holy on
the road regulate something triggered
the conversation a dog company boys work
up it is happened like that he said he's
a snake now and yes too bad he's dead
rest in peace and there's something like
that and I was like wait I was like Nate
dogs dead and then it just and then the
storm of clowning came you can't live
that bad now forever roasted him for a
strong two hours probably and then gave
it a break in ink I've gone I was I was
legit distraught I was like [ __ ] man
you know they dog he's an unsung hero
yeah no pun intended right yeah so you
met that uh that first post about the
cool kids right right and then they link
to it on their MySpace page and here we
are here we are here we are that's how
you you know but it was it was a weird
time because blogs were such a foreign
concept especially in Chicago yeah that
was not considered a cool thing at all
like okay I will go out and like you
know I would see like somebody from
crucial conflict or whatever and I'd be
like yo hey I'm starting this music blog
it's called fake short drive and you
know want to put up your music they're
like what do you mean like well you know
send it to me and I put it up like for
free they're like why would we give you
music I mean they just didn't get ya
they thought I wasn't saying they
thought I was trying to rip him off
right I was like no this is like the
future and it took some people to kind
of get it to believe in it will you I'm
just pictured these conversations so you
this is the future yeah sell me a CD
this is trying to sell me like a CD on
trunk there they got a hard copy and I'm
like yo this is not this is done
nobody's gonna be doing hard copies
anymore like you need to give it to me
put it online shoot your video you know
that's when people were still trying to
get their videos on empty
yeah yeah for premiere and it's like no
there's this thing called YouTube and
that's crazy to take that YouTube I
don't think a few years yeah YouTube
would start at five yeah that's not
that's weird to think about YouTube
would only been around for two years
when I started the blog right that's
just that's where to think about
limetube's only been around for ten
years 11 years in general because it
feels like we've had in our whole lives
at this point do without youtube I don't
know ma'am
it's kind of weird right yeah so you
know I was just kind of going that but
the first person to like embrace me and
get it but funnily enough was bump J
yeah yeah who's now and prezi supposed
to get out this month for robbing a bank
oh I was like the most street wait he
he's in the hideous move around yeah
move around was that [ __ ] I want to
start putting out of your DJ sets yeah
just real throwback all right all right
all right yeah I'm not sure I tell you
what to do just know that's a good
suggestion
[Music]
does it blend with the percocet
percocet he could have said anything
else besides Molly percocet why is he
making that so catchy that's gonna feel
wrong it's just that we're talking about
that percocet like come on like Molly
that's a terrible combination yeah
that's how you die kids are gonna die
off kids are gonna die
Molly burgers my it could have anything
yeah but percocet is literally one step
away from heroin right all right I mean
it's almost the same makeup but it's
like the opioid of opiates but this is
what people do they get hooked on
percocet and then they don't get their
prescriptions anymore or the
prescriptions get cut off and then they
end up going to the streets and getting
on that hair on and it's over and this
[ __ ] is saying in his books but
like in a percocet percocet
with the flu yeah hello it's dark dark a
song man you know the great thing about
the internet now is we can all
collectively listen to albums like at
the same time yeah yeah it's like
midnight on Thursdays
wouldn't it hit Spotify or Apple music
or whatever everybody's on Twitter
listening to it right in time and it was
like all at the same time that song
everybody was talking about mask off
like this is the hit this is the hit
yeah oh my god listen to it yeah and
then I play the hook and I'm just like
oh my god can't so don't feel right no
dart is so catchy though yeah I'm so
good that I I mean I'm so glad that I
don't want any percocet or Molly I mean
as bad as I mean it's bad will you put
yeah well Molly is fine it's Molly all
rappers are always talking about Molly
but don't overdo Molly
yeah but lately we're drink water yeah
drink water and just try not to drink
and if you gonna have Molly hi drew did
you have some Molly you know Chuck some
pepto with it cuz things can cut that
pept up with some alphas Elsa is some
imodium a-d you know they don't matter a
percocet don't cut it yeah no no
brothers that don't cut anything with
percocet oh you know what I'm saying
like Park is that like especially kids
they don't know what that
hell no they're like they find percocets
and then they eat that [ __ ] and then
their nose they're doing some yay I
think what Molly is Molly's are
stimulated right yeah yeah you got that
going in your system you're just trying
to get a heart attack yeah that's a
heart attack waiting to happen and it's
like you know it's one of these things
now where I have kids
yeah I got two kids now so I think about
music differently yeah yeah Molly
purchases welcome yeah yeah
now I'm like Vanessa bad like this is
doctor to actually kind of look at
things that for more mature perspective
yeah yeah it's probably not really a
good thing like lean like lean is in the
same family but it's I mean I don't know
how I've never tried it but I'm thinking
it's probably in the same cause it's a
downer to it I've never had it either
there's a long time when I wanted to try
was really yeah I got to try this I've
always I've always wanted to try it
could never find it though yeah no no
lean for me man you know why why is that
can't trust nuttin you got to put two
cups in yeah put two cups gotta have the
double Cup why the [ __ ] do I need a
second cup it's too danger that the
reason that have you heard why they use
a double condensation of something that
an in case like you know you pass out
like you got a blunt in your hand or
like a cigarette in your hand
hmm it won't burn through the two cups
Oh sort of protects a double layer of
protection Oh
so just in case you fall asleep on this
thing so when you're not up I think it's
more for the condensation oh that seems
like a weird after effect hero that's
like a byproduct like oh and it also
weights I fell asleep and it was all
good yeah
wait kind of say [ __ ] like cuz they
don't want it to slip out your hand
basically cold yeah oh you want to keep
the ice cold I guess you want to keep it
I it tastes better when it's ice-cold oh
and that's why you see it the styrofoam
at s'what double cup man yeah I thought
okay I thought double cup meant like he
was like double fisting I didn't know I
was it as a party boy I was at a rap
show and some cat was pouring lean out
it's a audience members in the front
rows mouth was it yes
like it was oh yeah you told me about
firewall just like yeah what the [ __ ] is
going on right now I'm okay of you
drinking
I don't want to say I talked about it
online went right when it happened but I
mean just cause it's old now he might oh
he might never be doing that in his act
anymore he might you know I've moved on
from that but it was crazy to see wait
wait is this the same guy that sprinkled
Molly on the fruit plate no not what we
just heard about an artist in the studio
session somebody was collaborating
within this person got mad because it's
a bunch of people at the studio it is
artists sprinkled Molly on all the fruit
flavors in the studio named people
eating fruit and then they were all
[ __ ] up later
yeah that's wild a party in college
wants to these wild East Coast girls we
do xanex punch Oh see that's that's not
right and I didn't even know but and it
was like yo what it was the girl okay
the girls were doing it okay here's the
questions I asked because I for some
reason I'm that just instinct truly
against that just how much how much how
many's a neck so how much punch what's
the ratio of the concentration level
it's just like epically you know what I
mean you put every Everclear is horrible
by itself but if you put Everclear in
like a big-ass tub of [ __ ] all of a
sudden everything so strong but you
gotta let people know xanax it's
well-known xanax and alcohol even a
small amount of xanax and alcohol leads
to blackouts
oh you drank
zenyk splints without knowing it I
didn't know how many I'd be old quick
blacked out yeah oh yeah EPS I mean I
was I I thought it was just jungle juice
you know what I mean yeah so you were
yeah Oh hairy Buffalo whatever the hell
this is an ex are there yeah I don't
really remember yeah I survived though
your parkas were still intact yeah
that's good that's good
so anyway bum Jay don't send us we keep
his trucks we come right back yeah so
bum Jay yeah he like sent me an email I
think he was like vanity googling
himself yeah and he saw that I was
writing about him and then they sent me
an email
they found my email because it wasn't
like easy you know there was this is pre
Twitter this is pre Facebook Facebook
was a huge it only college that he's it
and so just MySpace and so they hit me
up and they just started sending me
exclusives they're like we get what
you're doing you know you were we rock
with you Chicago thing they just started
sending me music and then do them I met
you know no ID and twist a legendary
track stir and Mickey Halsted and people
like that and you know then I got in
good with the cool kids and you know I
just kept kept you know building it
brick by brick yeah and then you know as
the blogs now if kind of I don't say
blogs are completely phased out but I
don't they're not as relevant as they
once were
yeah it's a social media right in
streaming sites have made you know cuz
it was like the wild wild west like the
blog game was a one-up on the man right
the music industry the the evil Titan of
the music industry like the people
taking the power back yeah we're gonna
post these artists I don't need record
labels and we're gonna have music first
we're you know or just putting your
music out for free is a big [ __ ] you
Yeah right
and then the label were like uh-uh nah
it might it might have taken them like
close to 20 years but they finally
figured it out right yeah there's money
back in the business again you know the
Imperius almost sunk them but now
streaming is like yeah there's money
back in and it's also crazy out like
vinyl is like the physical go to like
vinyl is like completely come back like
from what I hear like like vinyl sales
versus CD sales are like a vast vast
like increase in margin or difference
yeah you could buy vinyl albums at Whole
Foods now yeah but Outfitters oh yes you
don't I mean it's a different yeah but
on me I'm like I don't even want that I
you know give me streaming all day now
yeah it makes it easy
right I mean think about that you have a
you know this computer in your pocket
where you have access to every other
stream inverness streaming sucks for the
[ __ ] artist oh man well yes and no
you know I think it needs to be figured
out cuz I think it's only like 5% our
pen if our people are using streaming
right now well once that market grows
and more people come on board I mean do
you guys use it and I do I don't use you
pay for the premium at all like Apple
music Apple music I got title and I got
the Pandora without commercials so you
pay for all those right yeah and see
that's that's good you're supporting it
like so it's not still buy some albums
yeah yeah good
so it's you know if now you have to
retrain people you're like to do this
now because like people like it's you
know it's 10 bucks a month for Apple
music spots like 10 dollars a month
look whatever spend oh my go let me tell
you about a time yeah you had to work a
full day at a job to go buy a physical
CD from a store with four corners in it
and that you could had to listen to
until you can afford to buy another one
right you know that's where we were yeah
or they know where the cases what I've
found I don't know if this is other
people's habits but with me when I when
somebody comes out with a new project
and I listen to it on streaming now
check it out you might have some good
tracks on it that I like but then I kind
of just move along and back into the the
[ __ ] that I was already listening to or
get it you is no connection because you
didn't really say oh it's midnight oh
it's a new album by this person boom let
me listen to this huh I'm sorta into
that on to the next [ __ ] we don't really
unless you a fan fan you don't really
sit with stuff now say well every skit
yeah you know when the beat changes to
the next like yeah dog stops like you
don't know the transitions anymore like
you don't know every song well yeah
there's so many yeah it's like I know
just like and then when you have a phone
with this many gigs and this many albums
it's like you don't you don't even get
to the album sometimes on the phone but
you don't even get to it you're letting
people
come ridiculous like yo there you know I
remember when you know 98 when DMX
dropped two albums in a year
yeah right year bad different spectrums
of the year yeah now it's like futures
like drop an album every week yeah yeah
like how can you consume all this stuff
yeah a lot of people love super for the
currency I'm a huge currency fan but I
don't have all that [ __ ] man it's too
much it's too much it's too much music
too much music too much TV content it's
too much content man lots of content
people everybody's trying to make some
stuff yeah cuz you know it's easy now
there's no point of Barrett and there's
no like barriers anymore what you got to
do is you got a drop exclusive stuff on
vinyl only with like books and funky
stuff like kits you know what I'm saying
that'd be a good that'd be a good
marketing technique in like no mp3 no
stream and just vinyl only it figures
out how to rip it it's on blah yeah two
hours later they get a free
I'm already I'm already shaking with
anxiety from when we go down to South by
Southwest and try to give me their CDs
oh my god bro I don't have a car here
and I'm not putting this in this neck oh
make it to my xbox yeah do you have a
link or something yeah what am I gonna
do with this giving me this burden of
this physical CD thumb drive give me a
thumb drive don't even give me that just
email me yeah I think email me a link
yeah I like to talk to some hard data on
the how many like mixtapes
hotel maid's throw away yeah
every morning yeah I mean or that
wouldn't daily I mean I've never brought
one home with me yeah I've never
listened to one yeah yeah they give you
on 6th Street yeah yes it's crazy you
know I have a buddy old friend I've
talked about this before
old friend it just hits me up out of
nowhere yo man I'm trying to get inside
a rap game can you help me out just yeah
I'm just I'm rapping and stuff can you
help me
okay you got a you got a SoundCloud you
got Instagram you got Twitter you got
because there is that link you got any
links for me no just help me out like
what the [ __ ] you talking about help me
with my music where's the music say
where the [ __ ] is the music then he got
upset he got upset Oh check you got too
big for the people on your plan you talk
about and he actually I bring it up cuz
he I was leaving a barbershop in my
parents neighborhood today and I walk up
the barbershop he pull up on me and I
was like where's the [ __ ] music
don't ever [ __ ] talk to me like that
again you ask me about help with me
where's the [ __ ] music I got the
music yelling yeah whatever [ __ ]
you just pulled off now just in the
street screaming at his car now he kind
of new is this like when I'm of other
talk crazy on the phone or in text then
they see you too he like hey HB I might
not [ __ ] you bro yeah don't ever talk
yeah so do you I imagine now with how
the site is grown you just probably feel
the pressure or people trying to make
you feel the pressure of their dreams
yeah absolutely
I mean I get guilt trips threats all
kinds of weird messages in my I mean I
what I like to say cuz you won't put
them on or something yeah because you
know we've had some success with some
you know big artists that have kind of
come to the site and you know started
off you know at like chance yeah I know
probably being the biggest and then
Chief Keef and King Louie little dark g
herbo you know saba Mick and known it
like we were always were posting them
from the beginning before they got
national attention yeah and so I think
people automatically think that they can
just you know a post will change their
life right but it's not like you have to
have a full plan you've got to be ready
so they call ya they come to you acting
like this one song is gonna yes like
changing you make me rich yeah what yeah
so you gotten threats like yeah yeah
come shoot you know one time this is
funny you being from the west side
you'll appreciate this yeah I did a top
50 Chicago rap songs list for complex
like eight years ago or something like
that I think I'm in triple darkness step
to me at a twisted video shoot because I
didn't put their song on there Oh set
with me yeah I had to apologize when I
redid the list I got it on there when we
we we revisited it yeah yeah yeah we put
it on there do you feel like it was an
omission it was it was a mess up it was
a mess up but if you've ever written
anything which I you know yeah I don't
know if you guys have or not band sure
you you've done guest posts on things
like that right you you get edited yeah
right so you have an editor you come you
come with your picks but they can say no
I don't want that yes I slice slice yeah
we want five more Kanye songs yeah and
you know sometimes you know that's
that's crazy to think about too because
you you're dealing with Chicago rappers
so you're dealing with some thugs yeah
and some gangbangers yeah so like you
could you can really you can just give a
better of you and know and just try to
keep it positive yeah and if I don't
like something I will give honest
feedback but people don't want honest
feedback they want you to say this [ __ ]
is doping yeah and you know make them
rich right maybe if you say yes you say
honest feedback yeah so getting hit hard
coat it with a little Molly on them man
those ad-libs
are passionate passionate with the
ad-libs it's like you know the people
were 35 and it's like yo the rest of it
garbage you know you might want to just
try to figure something else out because
it's not that easy you know once you
once you get over 30 years old yeah yeah
no yeah yeah amazing amazing you gotta
be undeniable Jay Electronica
Rick Ross 2 Chainz type of bang I mean
you gotta be yeah yeah two changes even
already in the game he just had a
rebranded right yeah titty boy that's
something like that yeah
because as you get older that net your
network you know it dries up your 1819
you got a vast group of friends that are
still engaged I was still going out
party and hanging out and read music
yeah because word of mouth is still them
you know radio they say statistics show
that's still the the biggest form of
music discovery yeah I don't know if I
believe I don't know that that dad is
correct but yes the Nielsen report and
then the second biggest one is word of
mouth no which I agree with yeah
basically a hype right and you know you
know you're doing a lot more talking
about music via word of mouth when
you're 21 as opposed to 30 yeah yeah or
and you know you still got that mind
state like we're like I got some [ __ ]
that I need to put other [ __ ]
on to like I got that like secret
knowledge I'm gonna be the one that
breaks it to my friends I take pride in
that just cuz I'm a DJ yeah so it's like
you still lives in you yeah so like when
people come up to me like what is that
like a part of me a part of me like
feels like great good doing my job yeah
you know but I think everybody but
everybody's got mmm everybody's got that
inside of them I feel like it's not just
me I just have it more in a magnified
level but everybody has that feeling
like oh I just put this [ __ ]
onto some dope [ __ ] saying
yeah well which artists have just really
impressed you when they approached you
and you saw they're playing and how
their operation was and and howdy just
had things laid out with you like oh
[ __ ] y'all got this together who really
I mean obviously chance with ya person
you know you're friends with them is
just I was impressed with them from the
first day that I met him he came to my
office when he was like 18 yeah a nice
just fresh out of high school you know
he came in here just kind of like BAM
okay this kid this kid has it like I
already did he already have any kind of
oh yeah like once yeah like I think the
[ __ ] you talking about video yes either
about to drop and this is from tenday
his first project yeah either that was
about to drop the video was about to
drop yeah yeah or they might have showed
me like a private clip of it okay and I
was like okay like this is something
like this kid this kid's gonna be
and because it was very different than
like the height this was like the height
of chief keef okay god she's real is
like the thing so this was like a
complete looks like the yin and the yang
of it I'm like okay we get it that
everybody likes drill right now and
that's when I was like the most popular
person like every single record label
was calling me oh you must every ANR can
you get us Chief Keef can you get us
cheap oh [ __ ] if you can't get this Keef
who sounds like who can you get it
sounds like yeah and the whole time I'd
be like there's other kids here but let
me get back to the chance thing so yeah
I just knew it liked the way he carried
himself and they're like we're gonna do
this I'm gonna roll it out this way I'm
gonna go to the high schools and sell
tickets to my show you know and like he
was already playing shows on his own
independently promoting I mean like you
know 18 I was just impressed with that
yeah so I did another list for complex
that was like top 10 Chicago rappers to
watch out for and I put chance on that
mm-hmm
and this is before he even put out his
mixtape so I was just kind of I gambled
and that you know turned out to be a big
win but he just kind of seemed like he
fit he got it yeah
you know he had a plan he saw where he
wanted to go that's smart that you yeah
that you flipped that that you're like
this cuz you must have caught a lot of
[ __ ] for putting up putting out that
drill shot right people probably like
rats but you know what the I think the
worst of it came what would it threats
like what cuz here's what I pitched
remember pitchfork carbonize [ __ ] when
he goofy [ __ ] like that I think anybody
to a gun range yeah like you have to
like my job is to let people know what's
hot here right yeah and these kids were
putting out videos and getting a million
views yeah and they weren't even known
outside of their neighborhood like they
may be known outside of Englewood or
wherever they you know yeah like they
were doing high school parties but their
music was like affecting people yeah
like it so you have to cover it and I'm
not saying that I thought it was the
great not everything was the greatest
but people needed to know about it right
I'm not glorifying it but you know but I
think a lot of it that the backlash came
from the rappers who were waiting their
turn that were like thought they were
gonna break out yeah and then it's like
BAM Here Come all these 18 year old kids
didn't pay the dues you know they're
young they don't care they're not
respecting the old peer they're not
going by the traditional
pop yeah which is [ __ ] what you know
what I'm saying I mean it's just you
make music who's just shooting a video
in a grandmother's house with the shirts
off a lot of people locally were upset
yeah
because it was like these kids came out
of nowhere and they're all getting
record deals it's like it's six months
like 12 people had a major label deals
yeah and then like in the five years
previously like the only person that got
a deal was like Jeremiah he's named a
rapper yeah yeah so like it was it was
it was interesting time that's when like
yeah guys like chance and rocky fresh
and vic mensa who had a different cell
wait what happened - rocky fresh so okay
as long as not dead okay okay I wasn't
there I just want to make sure he's
alive and well
I booked rocky right before he got
signed to MMG I think when did he get
signed 2012 20 was all 2012 all those
people got those 2012 yeah I booked
Rocky we did a show it uh was out
pitchfork after party or something is
that the one that it was the Twitter
party was Kyle Kinane was on that when
suddenly it was at Lincoln Hall yeah
yeah I mean what was the one off we were
kickin it at yeah I mean this is six
years ago he was at bottom lounge
upstairs all the flying low that was
Danny Brown was DJing nah no no was that
a different flying line those was DJs
that one okay Erica we did Eric Andre
show live cael's and uh Fozzie Mack The
Breakfast Club kids before on it's right
but you did we were hanging out there
the year previously member was upstairs
oh yeah oh yeah that's what Danny Brown
was DJ oh yeah we want chillin we were
okay kickin it like drinkin name yeah
Ernest was there yeah yeah yeah used to
be done hanging out with Hannibal at a
pitchfork yeah
because the VIP areas is was fun what
was the first event you put on in
Chicago um the first event that I did
you know prior to the one like the big
stuff that I'm doing now I did like just
to showcase yeah I wasn't anything big
and I did it with a promoter who didn't
tell me that he didn't pay in the artist
charging people to get in and he ran out
the back door with the money really yes
show it was like we're going to put the
door you know he was like don't even
worry about what's gonna put your name
on it you promote it you know and we'll
get everything taken care of and then
we'll split it down the middle when
we're done huh
is that promoters still active on the
city's gone I was done with him after
that he's gone from the city and
everything he might be in LA now yeah I
still he'll pop up every now and again
I'll see him and then we'll apologize it
was sorry about that man and like he
like would pay pound me in little
increments like life or the next
like seven years I get like a 20 like a
random $20 would you know you're paying
off that debt I'm like dude don't slice
just stop all at once uh no yeah I don't
even like I've forgotten about this like
whatever it was it just gets angry when
you get and he was like god it was like
the back door was like open it was just
like swinging like you know gone gonna
come to word the promoter go man I'm
like uh I don't know and then I didn't
see I was like texting no no that was
like my first horror story that's hands
and then I linked up with red bull in
2013 for the sounds like red bull sounds
like program yeah and I've been doing
shows with them since we've been doing
them all over the world you know we do
them in Chicago LA get some stuff in
Sweden so Canada so that's you know
that's kind of like the new ventures
doing shows and events and things like
that yeah I got a new affection for Red
Bulls as I haven't been drinking a
couple weeks
been crushing Red Bulls man yeah had way
too many last night yeah you know if you
drink like if you mix it you know
drinking alcohol with them you have like
more than five or six like you have
family well forever
it's like the opposite of ours it's like
the opposite of lean right you just get
real turnt up and can't stop did the
kids woke up yet that you that was up
yeah you uh yeah and I was out late I
was upper
how would a kid out of kids one-and
two-and a-half Oh babies he spends one
also and a half he spends most of his
time making snacks that's what I said
man listen you think you're exhausted on
these weekends and then once you got to
chase some kids around the house and
like make them snacks and change diapers
and get them in and out of car seat -
the whole thing I never thought about
making snacks easily energies low you
got it yeah you gotta give them snacks
take a nap so like they take a nap and
you get to relax for a little bit then
you got to do all the other [ __ ] that
you couldn't do when you were chasing
the kids around yeah it's bearable quits
yeah it's a new thing what are they do
they have what do they like to listen to
yeah there's been videos online of like
a baby cry and in a play
Molly percocet and the baby starts
smiling I'm that kid we get like yeah
young little baby it made me feel better
that the baby was white this is so funny
look at Molly percocet yeah yeah you
know cuz they like they like should like
the trolls soundtrack yeah the movie
like the songs on that and though
they'll hear some rap sometimes unlike
it but yeah sometimes it just they don't
they're not feeling that so much it's
too much for him yeah yeah I think
future might be too much for future some
heavy things going on everything he said
and he said I paid for my mistakes like
a drug deal yeah it's like my head
exploded
yeah I'm depressed yeah
future like his the he's so dark number
one he's got this dark side to him but
his uh his production is undeniably good
like it's they've worked out some kind
of a formula or some kind of a magical
equation algorithm to get Pete like
doesn't get babies to stop crying right
so he could say whatever the [ __ ] he
wants and he's still gonna have a hit on
his hands right because his delivery his
persona everything it just works so well
that's why he could get away with just
going molly Perkis right mother QC built
into that because I'll tell you the
first time I heard future was on this
young ZZ track called way to go that's a
great song
it's a great song until future comes on
and he sounds horrible and I was like
who is this hero you know like that has
like six bars on it or something yeah
and they made me upset cuz that the song
it sounds like it sounded like one of
them tracks where he might not have
recorded it with Jeezy like a male of
the male in it was a if this sound is so
late so disconnected from the vibe now
for me will be he wasn't was he rapping
normally was he doing he doesn't sound
like he sounds nice I woke up brother at
morning dude where girls want a big
party up in there live it's [ __ ] suck
yes stuck in my like at the same time
future yeah I hate that verse so much Oh
like wallah magic like those songs gonna
dip with some sweet white girl for the
pink
I'm going so caught up in the moment 110
foot 10 ten-four
the animal has his hand his fan his face
in his hands
stop I like this hope so but he just
comes in this morning
white goes for the pink pony I'm caught
up in the life cuz that was a Mike was
like when my quills beats and that's
when he started using the filter effect
on ya his tracks
yeah so yeah that was future is very
different from that yeah now definite
him before him no see yeah I've seen him
live I haven't uh haven't met a visible
here he was in a Houston two years ago
uh directs people reached out to me to
do this event for Houston appreciation
week when they were doing a tribute to
bun beat and I know bun a little bit and
they wanted me to do a speech you guys
why I'm like alright cool man
like but you know butters I don't know
him that well I've met him you know
several times in a few different cities
always been nice but I'm real thanks
guys I don't know if I'm qualified for
this but whatever is it it was me I
think the mayor of Houston spoke Jay
Prince what yeah you were with Jay
Prince oh my god I was when I was around
I wasn't like talking with Jay Prince
but he was one of the other speakers so
what but to be a fan yeah definitely a
fan yeah and I guess Drake knew that
made Drake was and he asked me they
brought me down to speak at this thing
and so it was cool I did a quick speech
a couple jokes and and you know spoke
mine spoke my piece about Barbie and
afterwards
later that night was the future concert
and so we all go in
it's in this i forget the name with a
venue but it's like a circular spinning
it's a spinning stage and we come in the
side or whatever and then we we have to
go to the pit and walk there with Drake
and his crew but you walk I guess people
you walk down an aisle we walk down an
aisle before a future went on and his
people on both sides like making an
entrance like a reverie buddy's looking
right it was just what is like to hang
out with Drake this [ __ ] is crazy but
yeah it was the first time I saw a
future live you know I I didn't I had I
didn't know a lot of songs I think I may
be new March Madness you know and he was
saying some [ __ ] I was like What did he
say
I spend a check on the [ __ ] he mumbles
July bubble wraps a lot yeah yeah yeah
but I interviewed him like I don't know
five four or five four years ago maybe
something like that
yeah four years ago yeah whatever the
album was that he had that song trophy
with Kanye that awful song with Kanye
and they was like the first single
dedicated to Sierra and Kim Kardashian
do you remember that song No so Sava
bombed the song bombed and but even in
Chicago doing press yeah so I was
interviewing him for Cricket Wireless
yeah yeah at like a building downtown
are they still your wireless provider no
they gave me phones but I too angry
[Music]
[Laughter]
and when I interviewed him like
literally he pulled up and there was
three SUVs
this isn't future now this is future
like four years ago right yeah it was
like a black car SUV and another black
car behind it right
all security yeah I'm like why does
future this like who is this Beyonce or
is this like he had like five security
guards with him huh and we did an
interview in like an office building
like a Corp like at the Aon tower and he
had his security guard stand in the
hallway and guard the door it's like in
an office like is already an agency
everything's clear already there's
nobody's gonna bum-rush yeah to try to
get in there yeah so people are paranoid
man is paranoid you might just be a
paranoid guy that's expensive I don't
know I haven't looked in the security
rates lately Hannibal have you know just
out and about but I was looking at sofa
South by Southwest the South by
Southwest cuz that's all young people
and South myself yeah to get from one
place to another is it's been it could
get what pass says maybe 2012-2013
Southwest was the one where we did the
show a chance you were there yeah I did
Master P like you came early in the day
yeah you had the show right that was
like probably started getting kind of
crazy for you yes are getting a little
weird yeah that year and then yeah it's
how I saw it can get a bit because
everybody's [ __ ] young you know what
I mean yeah
it's like I talked to a a buddy of mine
Jermaine Fowler he got he's got has a
show on CBS now superior donuts and when
he got that show cuz I remember him when
he was starting when he was 19 moved to
New York
he's like 26 27 now got a sitcom on CBS
black comics don't really get CBS you
get an NBC show maybe ABC Fox CBS's you
know it's not tough yeah that's
different it's just they just don't do a
lot yeah and so a totem it's a difficult
thing
so different this is my is it there's
there's Urban Outfitters famous nests
Cracker Barrel famous
I'm Urban Outfitters famous I've gone
into Urban Outfitters and a mother it
becomes a [ __ ] problem all this yeah
let's shut it down but isn't like all
[ __ ] I need to grab this shirt and get
out of here I'm getting weird but I've
never been bothered in a Cracker Barrel
that's cue me and many a crack of
barrels on the road and not once has
anyone ever even looked in our direction
just playing that little golf tee game
at the table do the store go to store
carefree and Cracker Barrel frolic is it
hard for you to go to like a lot of
places it's not hard but it could just
exist kid just people I hear people just
get really just do weird stuff like I
saw somebody tweet at me like hey man I
didn't want to bother you and sorry I
took this picture and this is me like
chilling with a pool cue in my head
people doing weird stuff like that like
a surprise like yeah everybody but I'll
see like people think like people I
record at during a show people will hold
their phone like just openly it's not
like cover it but they hold it like this
like in the middle of the chest as if
that makes it invisible [ __ ] is that the
owners that activate the cloak feature
is wrong with you what's wrong with you
the club but yeah I do my best man I
mean I definitely you know sometimes
people are just weird and enforce it I
do my best to just try to but at home
and Chicago was it
that is it worths he roars like bears on
the spot yeah it's really on the spot if
he's on the spot and the night is not
even about it's the night and it's the
people and it's where the [ __ ] moon
is cuz I've been I've been to some bar
and it'll be chill and I go to the same
bar a different night and is it gets it
gets weird but it's an interesting just
you know you said because I'd like to
observe people with ya you know interact
with people but it's just my father's
just definitely get weird and my [ __ ] is
I couldn't imagine if it was crazier I
would I would probably freak out no
because I got but you certainly had me
been the same person since like I met
you yeah so it's not like you're like
super unapproachable or anything like
that but I'm sure I can get annoying
right yeah but I've seen other I see
weirdest [ __ ] like I was uh when I went
out to LA last week I happen to be on
the same flight as chance chance was
going out there to shoot something and
it was a it was a red-eye and so I'm
chilling Chen I'm in the aisle seat I'm
like let's say I mean to be and chance
is in 3d so one seat behind me and
across and this my father somebody came
from coach it's an asleep and then his
dude like came up why he was sleeping
hey what's going on man can I try to
wake up a be somebody for a pageant boy
yeah that's yeah that that would be
crazy
yes well gets how famous he is sometimes
yeah cuz they'll just pop up places and
like trying to shake his security guard
you can't do that anymore but I remember
like a year or two ago you just come by
like he was this girl come by himself
yeah it would just be like he'll be
walking through and it would be like you
know miles of splitting the season yeah
do it everybody in the party would just
follow him like wherever he went
yeah yeah I mean you probably shouldn't
just be coming out here like that
anymore like it's yeah you know I went
to one of his little going-away parties
at the East Room once and I didn't visit
because uh Zack the owner like I didn't
know what was really going on there he I
found us out later but we like went to
the side like this
door side thing and then all of a sudden
we're on this like stage area and all
these people are just like standing
around a state like fiendishly standing
like what the [ __ ] I'm like there's no
DJ up here what the [ __ ] is going on I
didn't know and there's like four
security guards that's sure enough I
look around and there's just chance then
and there with a couple of his friends
and I was like oh yeah oh here's I
forgot the detail there's this there's
these two cute girl because I walked
through the door right away these two
two two cute as girls just start
hollering I mean like hey what's your
name just trying to get the chance you
know so they were just like what's your
name what's going on with you my name is
I'm like damn I got it today cert the
jacket yes they amazing jacket yeah in
that and then and then I told her I see
chance I'm like ah and then I went and
said what's up and then I got the [ __ ]
out of it it was just a weird it was a
weird vibe because they had to like just
rope that area off for him because every
body was just being this least staring
cracker real famous now yes the wildest
as a general weird ask question and I
and I hate to put it to you cuz I hate
when people give me generalized
questions but what some [ __ ] just sticks
out we like goddammit I can't believe I
saw that happen
what right just some shocking or even
you doesn't have to be a entertainment
thing does anything in like a weird porn
video something on worldstar maybe even
something foul your kid said that you
couldn't even believe your kid just said
that what the what was that what was
that man I see this is a tough one you
caught you favorite concert I'll tell
you my favorite concert and I'll get
back to that one but I was gonna say man
one time I went to a party at P Diddy's
house yeah in which house my oh my
you've been the
Miami house no that was that it was much
like coming into your house today
yeah take my shoes off but he had
slippers for everybody
I'm gonna get slippers for everybody but
I was what I want when I little boxes he
had like professional like the ones you
get it like if you state like the
peninsula or like some real fancy
hooking just Lana
uh of them just in rappers yes wrapped
up like brand-new oh wow
so he gets more of a for every party for
every more I was thinking oh wow I was
thinking maybe you know you just [ __ ]
put him back in the box people not
really putting too much where town
slippers and less spill a drink on him
yeah someone's got [ __ ] up feet but
the craziest thing that he had to do
from Junior MAFIA working security at
the front gate little it wasn't little
season was d-roc did the guy that no one
knows yeah so you think he did that to
want did you take the dude needed a job
or you think he did that to create a
vibe and expectation at a party were you
like oh [ __ ] there's guys when I was the
only one that recognizes them though ha
he was doing in Colorado he was so
caught off guard that I knew who he was
uh he was do definitely doing him a
favor yeah I know it's something else
weird that happened one time
Twista got me a birthday cake a surprise
birthday case well that's nice of
Twister thanks since you play so I was
at a party with him yeah we were
celebrating like our birthdays together
and you got the same birthday as yours
close like a week yeah and he rolled
over a cake to my table nice that was
kind of strange that's what he tastes
strangest things that did the DJ switch
to song up as the cake approached I
can't remember I was so shocked yeah
that's what we're calling it these days
I was so shocked I don't remember the
music man I was so shocked so suck last
night man I was so shocked
make your next move with squarespace.com
get 10% off when using promo code
Hannibal that's promo code
Hannibal squarespace.com get your
website tagged get your money right
change your life and in your dance
better
what sure Squarespace ladka roll call
Hannibal 10% off everybody wants to be
backstage because everybody thinks
that's where the cool
yeah and you know 9 times out of 10 back
things not that fun really not that cool
and even side stage the sound is
terrible unless they move the speaker
that you can hear it you just maybe look
but it's better to be so the worst parts
of always doing um shows is dealing with
entourage entourage dealing with green
rooms yeah dealing with you know people
trying to get size takes people want to
be on stage and so whenever I do show us
now I do it where it's wristbands cuz if
you get the passes like the sticky
passes you know people pass them back
yeah so you wonder like how you go
backstage sometime and there's a hundred
people back there but you know you only
gave out ten all-access passes yeah but
it's booming back there because people
will find a way to sneak in no matter
what he'll get in there yeah whatever
and that's the hardest thing to deal
with everybody nobody wants to be a fan
anymore everybody wants to be the star
the entourage and like everybody's nap
chad all that yeah if the whole room was
on their phone
yeah just phones over yeah lots of
phones everywhere that's also [ __ ]
tonight um but like sometimes like you
know people want to go to the green room
especially if you're dealing with like a
street artist yeah like you know like I
don't know if this was a situation but
though people don't to walk through the
front they got to get patted down you're
going straight to the green you can walk
in or whatever god yeah so that's not um
yeah that's not good you know one time I
opened for Cameron at the Congress like
I was DJing like in the
and then all I wanted to do I barely got
I don't even think I got paid for I just
wanted to meet camera yeah I just wanted
to smoke weed with them so it's like I
had the all axes though I did it I got
my all-access badge I went back to his
room knocked on the door and this dude
comes out
big-ass dough and he literally had like
he was literally strapped he had like
the straps and then two guns just Bam
Bam on his chest and I was like uh just
well I just got the DJ I want to smoke
we can run and that's not that was your
tone just asked I want to learn to get
the try to get the scene I got a little
okay I got a little dirt well you got
when you see two guns in someone's chest
as you know what I learned the guy
didn't have like a badge right that he
just look just strapped cameras been
shot before
yeah I mean I'll give him that I
understand why he's guys you know so I'm
okay so my tone was more like hey man I
just wanna meet camera smoke some weed
or whatever and he was like he's like he
looks at me a little bit and he's like
hold on and he kind of like closes his
door like you know I could hear real
quick and he's like nah man he saw smoke
with you and that's it slammed the door
and that was a camera story that was
well it was just so disappointing to me
but it was like well that was relating
to the gun thing yeah but it was just
like so over that I was like I did a
camp show once and was it labeled well
first of all it was at Lincoln Hall
which is like a 500-person room yeah and
like 2,000 people showed up yeah
everybody was trying to get in this cuz
yeah three hours show or whatever yeah
and cam missed two flights yeah that's
not like me yeah okay
are you are you moving on like camera on
time like you just miss flight sight but
I make my shells but I miss my flight
yeah he missed two flights yeah and then
eventually he got there and I think he
came straight from O'Hare straight to
the venue and everybody was like warning
us like okay when cam shows up he's
gonna be probably half 30 to 100 people
with them
32100 that's that incredible range that
you mean you operate differently to
handle 30 people differently than you
handle a have any more people right
that's 70 more it could have been 50 I
don't yeah I was shocked I'm so shocked
wait they all were flying with him no
but cuz he you know he's has heavy in
Chicago oh you know West Side oh yeah
yeah as opposed to okay right
he always raps about the west side of
Chicago and you know being out west or
whatever so words were expecting a large
crowd yeah even still if you've even if
you visit Chicago a lot like 30
you got 30 people here like all of them
I like all the time enough get them all
in for all 70 that many that's a lot
he's a lot that's a heavy but he he came
to SUV pulled up we're like bracing
ourselves he jumps out by himself yeah
that's it yes just me really Mike Wow
came to Mike he walked onstage performed
and then he went up to the green room
and hung out party with everybody no
guys with guns didn't not a guy with a
guy so he just was there like his
manager was in that's very that's a very
opposite story know what it is what they
thought to you was a threat hey if
anybody aging to come into this world
you send the guy with the guys yeah they
was scared of you
they closed the door that security guard
was like oh we didn't think we beat that
one we got really strange that's really
strange that he just even camera on for
like he's not like what there's there's
a story that he got robbed once and she
got like he got robbed for his Dipset
chain he did
yeah yeah there was a story about I
can't remember where they do you have if
you're at this becomes a young buck from
g-unit got this G and a spinner chain
stolen no it was Cameron it was okay I
mean iris pacifically remember it was a
camera on story and so I know he's got
you know he's probably he's gotta watch
himself the guy's a flashlight you know
hanging out on the west side you know so
I'm surprised that he just came through
security one that other half of that
deposit you cuz he bought missed the
show he didn't want to mess it up if you
wait on those thirty people but that's
the thing are to show up and they're
like yeah I need everybody to come in
it's like everybody needs to come in
yeah and it's just the green room will
get tore up the green room gets
destroyed
yeah comedians don't move around like
that do or do they do you get something
like that
it depends on the city our eyes never
really gets that it depends on well in
net move around too crazy but obviously
if I have a Chicago show if I'm doing
Chicago theater then I need like 50 cars
right I want that many people how that's
family I get over well with any people
backstage yeah hey y'all don't some
where people be backstage and I'll be
like throwing subtle but non subtle here
so yeah opener goes on about five
minutes huh starting up in a little bit
y'all wanna go ahead check out your
seats I think they got you in what was
that third row 19 and 20 check it out
over there tickets booked out of here
put that jameson down haha yeah remember
in Milwaukee it was like you had a
family reunion after the show well it
was a dull space it was it was it was
Milwaukee has this venue to Turner
perhaps the air it was the Pabst Theater
perhaps owns it so yeah what they've won
right on the river is so great how many
buildings that they've been able to
create and how they've been able to
support the Arts just based on millions
of dollars from a mediocre beer anyways
before the planet venue again
but they upstairs is beautiful he had a
huge Rome TV NBA Jam final player you
set up a bar up there it's very very
smooth situation then you just had a
show last night at the metro we had a
show last night at the Metro little baby
and g herbo and g herbo a.k.a no
limitations no limitation group that
house the green room situation exactly
as we had a certain amount of passes
list but that was out the window yeah
yeah man you know who the best people
that you'd only have to worry about like
if they asked me to put him on a list I
don't know save money kids yeah cuz they
will get into any show and they'll be
backstage at every show no matter what
always yeah like they're like don't even
worry about me man we're good I'm glad
we're back here don't even worry we'll
take care we're good yeah but it was
like the show was good you know schools
at the Metro yeah fun venue historic
iconic venue yeah and a lot of those you
know this uh I don't want to say because
they're not drill rappers but they're
more of a street element yeah it's hard
for those guys to do shows in the city
yeah they make it difficult to like a
guy like dirt every time I've done
something with Dirk it's been cancelled
like I was really do a talk with him at
the Apple store on Michigan Avenue
yeah and in like two hours before I get
a call from Def Jam like yep nope the
cut CPD shut it down what yeah Apple
store was like this ain't what we want
yeah the zing all right Peter Nate Dogg
but that they were like yeah I guess you
know they saw some kids lining up and
they're like uh-uh
yeah it's not coming in here Dan and so
they make it really difficult for that
but I just wanted to you know show that
that you can't do these in making you
know go successful and yeah and not have
too much of an incident I was thinking
about coming but you know like I think I
was too old for that show and now
yeah was you feel older rap shows when
you go to some of them it depends on the
raft show this was a young show yeah
like this was a very young I saw a girl
out last night she's I felt oh no how
would I use he's like 26 I was like when
didn't you go to that race murmured show
when your that's not yeah how was that I
mean I figured that leave out yeah you
know what I was upset about with that
that the guest list what I was supposed
to be all guest list yeah and then the
[ __ ] wasn't set up and so you know was
worse than being old at a race for ever
show is trying to finesse your way into
a race revered show I know I'm gonna
guess this I'm here to know excuse me I
wanted that but at 34 years old politic
your way into a race rivet show not a
good there's just like 16 your kids
blown by a low light 2016 I'm on a
racial look at DJ Oreos think DJ Oreo
you're supposed to put me on this no no
I just for you I don't have a list Oreo
said that I'll show you the text
messages from Oreo you don't have DJ
with low yeah okay alright never I just
I just it's so comical to me just
imagining you at the box office going no
no it should be under race mummers Perez
Perez on this murmur from hermit Birch
River next thing that I'm texting or
you'll get the [ __ ] down here now give
me that guy get we got in I think in
anakata
did hustle service was there so I didn't
feel this bad right Russell Simmons is
uh just cool like hustle I went to grade
school with hustle Simmons was a
promoter well what else
the industry industry doesn't know a lot
of stuff ANR maybe manager manager
smartest manage what's a great school
together at st. Paul Lutheran School
mm-hmm 8:46 Northman arch
Gago Illinois that your your jerseys are
hanging in the rafters
oh my simmons in the burst my career has
four points in four points in that one
game I remember I got two buckets that
game you play sports in high school
no I'm trashing sports no no sports you
know I'm not a big sports I don't even
like to watch sports
yeah no I'm nothing I'm not a movie I'm
not really a big movie guy either go to
baseball games I'll go to games games
okay you know I went to the World Series
okay here I'm not you herb oh nice we
went to the game together
like honestly medidas somebody'd his
business oh really oh no no and we were
sitting right in front of Bill Murray
video-out mana oh [ __ ] at the World
Series yeah oh [ __ ] murder good seats
Bill Murray grabbed my phone out of my
hand and like threw it on the ground cuz
you owe two eaten too much no he was
well I'm sure he was mad cuz herb was on
FaceTime to Hall it's like Soulja Boy
like he was on tea we were like right on
TV it's like all these famous people
were like calling herb while we were in
the seats yeah it's like Soulja Boy's
calling him like little bit he's calling
him yet yah TP everybody's like
facetiming him like he's like look I'm
on TV like we see you on TV yeah and
then just like then Bill Murray was
trying to get the crowd hype and like I
was doing a snap and I caught him I
caught him doing it he saw me filming
him he just grabbed my foot he said
we're not here to still people are here
to watch baseball and he threw it on the
ground
Oh according I had it on I have the
video have a video of him saying that I
have the video of him grabbing my phone
Oh exclusive your phone was unscathed
and break it didn't break oh man I'm
like Chuck does it go viral like this
would be on everything man he passed a
league like literally five minutes later
he's he pass out he passed out sweet
you should have wrote a note and put it
in his pocket and said you know I could
have took everything but I did yeah
and then don't fall asleep during the
World Series yeah no yeah no I think
that's worse falling asleep there in the
World Series than snapchatting sitting
right behind me it was able to like yeah
dude I'm ready it's drama time it kind
of stands in front of kids put some some
flubber footage in the new video maybe
I'll just post a flubber clip from
YouTube every day for the next week or
so just to let you it's an inside joke
you know
flubber just just just post it up you
know what it is I just like it there's a
there's a there's now people in the
music business who think of him as the
guy that's in flubber little yachty sees
like ghostbusters like Oh flubber was
his reference for not Ghostbusters not
any of the other
that Bill Murray's gonna I don't think
I've even I might have seen flubber once
at 98 yo you seen that movie Groundhog
Day it's starting to do from flubber
like every day you wake up it's the same
day broke flow way better yeah shops in
his range it's lovely we just been
talking about flubber for the past ten
me I'm glad I'm able to tell that's the
first time I've told this story that was
one of the weirdest things that wasn't
behind it stood he was kept winking he
kept looking at us and like waving yeah
yeah I'm like g herbo does not [ __ ] with
you yeah he's probably out down with the
mayor winking at us and stuff yeah not a
lot of people are down with when you add
a festival how many people run up to you
just start freestyling man it's not as
bad at a festival because people have
some decorum right and when people are
like this sometimes you know something
that depending on where you are and yeah
yeah it's industry people and
everybody's trying to be like really you
know cool and not you know break they're
cool they don't want to turn it down
yeah they're like but I used to have an
office in the city I don't have it
anymore yeah it was not a popular
building called lacunae I don't know if
you've ever been there
that Pilsen yeah and everybody knew my
office was there and so I had to like
start like locking the door and like
putting super locks on it when I was
there because like one day I just left
it unlocked like I'd gone to the
bathroom I came back I didn't leave my
door I'll just sit in the studio working
door just boom wide open I'm like what
the two dudes run in and they just start
rapping they're gonna kill me the way
the door like they basically just swung
it wide open
Wow I found a sound with a side of town
I'll [ __ ] your mom and I'll kill you
kids I was like
complete shock and I was like guys guys
guys what what's going on here that man
we just wanted you know we want you to
make this famous man you know it so I
start asking about the music you got
music you got a SoundCloud you got what
do you have and they didn't have
anything they're like man what we're
gonna do is right we're gonna do three
songs and blow up and get a three
million dollar record deal just like
ASAP Rocky
oh and I was like that is the most trash
game plan that's not yeah that's three
songs three songs I mean is crazy songs
but it shouldn't be your goats it should
be there it should be like this
accidentally happened like that yeah
yeah yeah three million but we did three
great song and all of us that's what
they told you that they they told me
that was her game plan cuz I look in you
and I as they went even shifty looking
at the ground like straight looking you
an eyes they're a little awkward but
yeah a little bit probably like you know
seventeen eighteen or whatever but then
I've had people come in with like
full-blown presentations yeah bounded a
like when you like may like a press kit
and like yeah you know trying to take it
a little serious and like yeah and
people like want to perform and it's
like this is really weird yeah this just
doesn't feel right we're like that's
kind of that's got to be the worst one
you could tell that they put all this
preparation they even went to Kinko's
and got the binder and everything and
the music is bad that sucks
it's just not there's no you spent so
much time in there your preparation but
you're preparing garbage yeah that's all
people can look the part they look cool
they dress yeah yeah yeah they look it
but then there's just there's just
nothing yeah yeah yeah you gotta be
really darned for you if you're in the
middle of a crap and an image for the
blog just crap it an image let me get
that get that corner how did somebody
just come in yeah you know what I'm crap
at images right now man you guys
like what the what is this and then
people would just come in and like
that's why I had to stop going up there
or I would have to go up there on like
non rapper time hours look like okay I
gotta be like 9:00 a.m. can we get the
address for your establishment it's not
open close the down I had it was way it
was a it was an office downtown yeah it
was in Pilsen Oh though it was in a
building with like a lot of other
offices and like clothing companies like
he frankly used to be in there his
studio used to be in there oh okay okay
like the guys from like fat tiger now
like had a little places so is there
like a buzzer system secure but it was
like it was the war security yeah I know
it's like super but it's like you know
people just walk in like if a door opens
people just walk in behind him you know
yes got you got you and being that it
was like you know the owner was like
friends is like King Louie and yeah yeah
there's always rappers up there who's
always like you know John monopoly had
like a little space up there so it was
like music and there's a thing that says
fake Shore Drive oh yeah there's a neon
huge neon light that says fake short
drive like what the arrow pointing to
huh like the owner of the building made
it and there's like it's just like fake
short drive like on the wall is a huge
yeah painted mural so everybody knew
where was so that's why you're getting
your doors kicked in okay that's good to
know so it wasn't like it wasn't
discreet or anything so you shut it down
now it's not there anymore it's not
there anymore but the signs are still
there so people still like probably once
a week once every couple weeks people
will still tag me in the picture you're
in just stop by the office is that y'all
have been gone for over a year
I'm definitely not there okay but yeah
it would be like you don't have to go in
on rapper time so like beat get there by
9 or 10 and then out by 2 because it's
like after 2 or 3 like everybody's up
and people just coming in people just
like no coming on they're coming here to
sit down make themselves at home can I
get something drink you know yeah start
drinking them whatever Red Bull in the
fridge can I give you some insight on
this image you cropping right now kind
of working don't forget that I actually
have to do work right I think like if
you work at entertainment same with you
guys I'm sure that you think you kick it
all day yeah like we are kicking it
right now right ok but this is work yeah
yeah
you're practicing your riding you're
working on things you don't have time to
just [ __ ] all day every day but they
think that's how it goes yeah yeah I
like your nan rapper time five our work
around noon that's not xanax right and
then it's gonna take him two hours of
you ready and head up there yeah but it
would they would come at night to play
yo man I would get a text or like you
had your I had my phone hooked up to the
buzzer and I will give them like like
buzzer calls like all hours I finally
had to take it off cuz people be like
it'd be like 12:45 like on a Tuesday
people like yo man just so seeing if
you're in the office right now man just
just hit me back they'd leave their
phone number dance it was like would you
be wherever you were maniacally laughing
about the rappers you avoided yes I got
him yeah they would leave notes under
like people that I was specifically
ducking yeah keep coming up with like
leaving though so I haven't so you must
have at least you must have ducked at
least one or two [ __ ] that blew
up and you were like had a man I
shouldn't induct him I don't think I've
ducked one rapper that blew up really
never not once got that he got a good
idea T not not that I know of
okay good for you not that I know of
what happened but not that I wasn't like
you know I ducked uh yeah like
Thelonious Martin put a beat CD under my
door so my dad didn't do it away okay
yeah cuz you remember you remember the
hangar the hangar nine is this venue
that me and him used to do in college it
was like it was there for a while it was
a dope venue we'd do like a hip-hop
night there and whatever but the owner
Sally she like that you know bands would
just send her demos all the time and I
remember like looking at her desk and
there was just a compile of CDs and I'm
like do you go through all these and
she's like sometimes I go through some
of them but she's like for the most part
I just throw them out they just they
just keep collecting and I'm like who
have you passed up before that's famous
she I see there was a Smashing Pumpkins
Nirvana
Sonic Youth like just naming these a
laundry list of fuck-ups
yeah she's passed on a lot like a lot of
historical bands yeah and maybe I did I
just don't know yeah but I don't think
yeah that I have because usually you
you'll hear about them when somebody's
that good the cream tends to rise to the
top yeah yeah and of course you have
your people that you know fall through
the cracks that don't make it but for
the most part if they're good you're
gonna find out about them yeah yeah is
there yeah speaking of that is it
somebody that you were really high on
that it didn't work out for there's been
a lot yeah what more so more of those
than the ones that make it right you
know what I mean what usually is the
fact this is the factor that makes them
fail um work ethic is a big thing pretty
much loitering around things that out
there you know the hard part is getting
the record deal but that the hard part
is like once you're on or late like to
make it through like just cuz you got a
record deal it doesn't mean you're there
so maintain right yeah maybe you have to
get yourself hot enough to be put out
yeah so it's like people get a record
deal get a little bit of money they
start feeling themselves they feel like
they don't have to work yeah I feel like
they don't want to go rehearse
yeah they don't want to work on their
live stage shows otherwise Jaso sucks I
don't get booked anywhere they get
booked for maybe walk-throughs Club
appearances but they're not you know the
goal is that you want to start you know
doing arenas doing doing festivals but
you got to take that serious unless you
have like undeniable hits then you're
gonna get booked no matter how good your
life set is or not yeah
but you know you deal with a lot of that
homeboy management right Oh what
management is is is very problematic
because you know people flake on stuff
they don't treat things seriously
they're not all the time they're not
professional
um and then just you know the it's easy
to fall off when you start getting lazy
start getting company you know it's it's
it's it's so true but like money does
change you like that I've seen it
happens like it's just yeah you're
eating nice dinners now and you're
you're you're you get whatever you want
you could do whatever you want it's like
well I even work on these too much yeah
or maybe that just makes you feel
uninspired or maybe they like that takes
the inspir
the way to do better and it is a
different time now where I think people
want like I think it's just a goal maybe
not even be able to make it the goal is
just maybe to be famous right and then
it becomes like okay I'm famous now I
got like a million Instagram followers
like ha I'm famous like I don't need to
you know I can do other stuff yeah right
so maybe that's not as important then
but then you realize that people really
just want the music and the other stuff
what else just like a classic young mind
stain I feel like and that has a lot to
do with it being young and inexperienced
yeah yeah not looking at things like
from a career perspective yeah yeah
gotta think long-term man bars get your
bars together you got to have your
stickers
listen saw any artist listen to this I'm
gonna tell you how you make it you get
you goddamn stickers do stickers work
like that they used to I don't think
it's yeah you better have some crazy
stickers now yo there's a there's a shop
a block down my street that only makes
custom buttons so there's got to be some
kind of a niche for that there's big
sticker outfit here's the thing they got
that button shop find out what else that
person owns because they might own a
bunch other [ __ ] to make money and in
that button shop is their vanity project
or maybe they really struggle in selling
buttons it was doing all right I don't
know I'm not trying to count anybody's
money except for everybody if you can
make a million on some buttons in a
button show I'm in the wrong business
yeah all right drew barber yeah I'll
check out fake short dr.com yo that
ain't for coming to thank you guys for
having me time yeah it was awesome
Thanks
[Music]